[موسيقى]
ايام ويطوي العالم عام 2022 بتقلباته
وازماته العام لم ياتي كما كان متوقعا
هذا العام واجه الاقتصاد العالمي سلسله
ازمات متلاحقه ان سيبقى في التاريخ عاما
متعدد الازمات على حد تعبير مؤرخين
فمن الارتفاعات الحاده الاسعار وزياده
معدلات الفائده والاحترار المناخي وغيرها
وليس انتهاء بتداعيات الحرب الروسيه
الاخرانيه تاتي التوقعات بعام جديد قاتم
خبراء واقتصاديون يرون ان العالم لم يشهد
وضعا بهذا القدر من التعقيد منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
ازمات تزايدت منذ بدايه القرن مع الازمه
الماليه العالميه عام 2008 وازمه الديون
السياديه وهو باقي كورونا وازمه الطاقه
المستمر ابقى التشاؤم سيد الموقف لا سيما
بعد حرب اوكرانيا التي بدلت الاوضاع في ظل
توقعات بانتعاش اقتصاديا بعد كورونا
تضخم ومعدلات فائده اعلى سياسه المصارف
المركزيه للجسم تضخم والسيطره عليه غير
انها استراتيجيه تشدد الضغط على الاقتصاد
بزياده كلفه الاقتراض على الاسر والشركات
والدول ايضا
التوقعات تشير الى ان العالم بعيد عن
الركود المعمم للعمل المقبل اذ توقع صندوق
النقد الدولي نموا بنسبه
2.720 وفقا منظمه الامن والتعاون في
الميدان الاقتصادي غير ان التغير المناخي
يبقى من اسوء الازمات التي تتطور ببطء
براي خبراء ما يبقي طموحات الدوليه محدوده
لمواجهه هذه الازمه